moi tu sais mon ami blanc j'ai connu à
l'usiné on travaille
il me fait trop rire juste c'est qu'il
mange sa façon de parler
ce n'est pas parce qu'on rit que c'est
drôle mais en riant on peut faire bouger
les choses
on sait que ce dialogue et le partage
avec un sourire et c'est vraiment en
s'écoutant passe par là qu on peut
changer les choses
avoir un animal m'a permis de voir
d'autres facettes d'une personne de ne
plus me limiter à la couleur de sa peau
et mon esprit est plus ouvert je
comprends mieux les blancs jeudi avec la
web série
moi je n'ai ni blanc financées par le
conseil des arts de montréal l'équipe
veut tendre un miroir aux personnes
blanches pour les faire réfléchir au
racisme et aux stéréotypes pour qu'un
dialogue il faut pouvoir se mettre dans
la peau de l'afa la personne en face de
toi sinon ça qui arrive et il ya eu aux
doublons qui déconne et ça tombe sur
toute la communauté des bases des trous
mais loin tous des préjugés mais la
seule façon de combattre ça c'est
vraiment en allant vers la personne imx
et mon ami blanche
en fait elle s'appelle quelque chose
comme michel michaut réception de
l'après midi les capsules se moque des
maladresses et du racisme ordinaire qui
vécut au quotidien peut finir par peser
lourd
ma vie j'ai dit aob appelle moi qui
quittent parce que mon nom c'est qu'ils
attaquent des fois c'est un peu plus
compliqué à prendre de plus en plus
c'est le fait qu'on efface mon nom ça y
est j'ai l'impression que ça ait fait
partie de mon identité aussi
je tends à ottawa des artistes issus des
communautés attikameks anishnabe
haïtienne tunisienne congolaise et
camerounaise ont participé au projet
souvent on va mettre dans le même panier
les personnes racistes et les blancs les
personnes assises et mais c'est les
personnalités vivent tous du racisme
mais ils proviennent quand même de
hillion des réalités très différentes et
courage parce que cette diversité là
beaucoup ajouté au projet après les
capsules vidéo
la plateforme web et le quiz pour
apprendre à connaître les blancs ces
artistes invitent maintenant les
internautes à tourner des vidéos maison
pour présenter leurs amis blancs car
tout le monde gagne en avoir un ouais
ouais c'est bon d'avoir un avis blanc la
preuve depuis que j'ai mon ami blanche
passe à la télé je m'appelle plaisir tu
l'oms je suis fier d'avoir un ami blanc
ici m'a dit alexandre charti à du canada
montréal